welcome to see I'm playing who then MP I
find info I don't know this direction
Buster troika from Germany I don't have
a good score handsome three wins six
losses I don't know sometimes you get
opponents and you don't handle so well
and he seems to be one of them I also
think I always have black and he's
pretty decent this with one g 3g three
is he for those kind of lines a kind of
his special team and he does very well
with them Wow
whoo interesting
ok let's do we five he goes to e4 so if
i take fo and then 92 I don't know about
not just winning this pawn and you can
go at five but that looks there may be
at five threads at four hmm maybe I
thought that stat any good mm ok I'm
taking this I wants to go 96 land now
and get it back
yeah okay not bad very very weird
opening play but interesting probably as
I said not bad at all we should be 50
it's somewhat surprising
this taking age six greenedge five
gallons Queen a five chick I wasn't
check really convinced by this but I
felt that this should be a pretty decent
position what is he coming with b5 is
this some kind of a problem I thought
just be should be to whoop dee morning
be 5 p-3 laughs anyway and my king is
playing his king is not playing
look d 1 oak CA droop t for something
like that yeah is threatening one see
for now you probably have to do this so
if I go F for knight c6 see doing
something like that I don't know I can
go look at the ATM then rook c7 down
doesn't help all that much maybe I for
really not sure him 96 I didn't expect
that move only thought about night too
I'm to to c6 My dear King be three years
this route behave more and he's got the
check here as I said as some are don't
don't don't handle up games against him
well I don't know why what it is I mean
ever certain it was better before the
head i don't know i'm not very strange
check our sea point is still somewhat
dangerous check
what is a good game
check we wonder what they did wrong
there I mean this position must have
been pretty substantially better for
white with my king playing at his King
out out of it really don't think the
Seaport was the weakest but the position
is not not all that clear here I'm very
active maybe Luke c7 as a decent move
hampering my king yep that's not so easy
now to find a move maybe this for King
the aid
my somewhat pass up here
time where I am NOT not in that bad
shape here the support is kind of
dangerous check
it looks like promotion so we to
completely promote like this and Rupert
is seven maybe I can take g34 Luke ga ta
what ah come on this is just stupid
stuff how lucky can you be whipped g8
and I will see three know why didn't you
do look this is three I don't don't
understand check this is a super strange
game check
black resins get anything you suddenly
tons of mistakes there I really have a
hard time to believe that this should be
any good for black I have that my king
is playing his King is not playing I
mean don't tell me that that black is
fine yeah I'm a hard time believing that
but it was this was probably yeah we're
probably g3 was bad huh Queen if I ok
look the AI didn't the engine just wants
to go King be too and after that he said
put it in the corner I really couldn't
couldn't I could do that but it just
looks too weird I wanted to be active
maybe that was wrong Ruby Jade Jolie is
definitely winning would be six I Kingda
seven and Roxy 5 and black wins he
probably overlooked a maid or something
rugby 7s totally would that not so much
thank you sir King d8 king of six why is
that totally winning well thread is root
be a check King d7 night f8 mate oh yeah
mate just made I can resign check this
this check yeah kind of hanging on check
and this is really bad young trading
route be seven is much much better
still threatens lots of things yeah yeah
it was really lucky but now things are
not clear the engine says equal which is
kind of alarming for black jersey as a
pawn up here why this starting shouldn't
be better j c7 G to so yeah now this is
this is a screw-up yeah I really didn't
see that this is a I mean okay I can
promote now but this is not really
helping that much of you check look at
this check here that this is probably
losing the other two pawns are too far
apart I tried everything here 95 95
stopping the whole thing because of the
the check their blankets better and here
I'm just winning yeah I was a rather
weird game okay well thanks for watching